E aí
[Música]
e eu não sei vocês mas eu
invariavelmente me questiono de onde é
que vem os valores que a gente atribui
as coisas ou de onde é que vem os
conceitos que a gente dedica as pessoas
por exemplo vou tentar ter um pouquinho
mais clara nossa sociedade ela se
desenvolve de diversas formas já vivemos
sobre vários paradigmas diferentes
e agora aqui pessoal Existe uma forma de
reconhecimento e valorização que nós
adoramos repetir e ela se chama
meritocracia a meritocracia ela é sempre
invocada quando nós desejamos falar para
alguém que mobilidade social é possível
e que essa pessoa poderá chegar aonde
ela quiser dependendo unicamente dos
seus esforços Olha que interessante de
onde é que nós aqui no Brasil tiramos
nesse conceito eu fui buscar eu fui
tentar entender eu descobri que existem
várias fontes diferentes que dão origem
desse tema em contextos históricos
específicos eu vou eu vou estimular
vocês a pensar em um dele eu descobri
por exemplo que foi Napoleão que não
cunhou o termo mas definiu a
significância desse termo que que ele
fez não é para da Revolução Industrial
ele decidiu que para concorrer a cargos
públicos não necessariamente as pessoas
precisariam vivo de
Bom dia da realeza ou seja prêmios e
plebéia poderiam concorrer a cargos
públicos se ele se esforçassem o
suficiente para poder alcançar essas
posições Olha que interessante a vamos
falar um pouquinho mais uma história a
gente entende que agir nos Estados
Unidos a meritocracia chega por volta do
século 19 e ela determina a definição do
Summer ou seja todo mundo pode se tornar
uma pessoa absolutamente rica e abastada
se ela se esforçar o suficiente para
isso é muito interessante pensar que
esse conceito chega no brasil com
bastante força no ano de 2010 e dali
para frente ele é usado invariavelmente
todas as matérias de jornais e revistas
de discursos de pessoas que já
alcançaram uma posição social muito
expressiva por esforço próprio E aí eu
fico me perguntando o que que é esforço
próprio né gente que muda de contexto
determinado período da história Olha só
nós
Em uma sociedade cujo paradigma
dominante era focado na Iraque aqui na
força e por que que eu tô contando isso
no passado porque a gente já superou
Essa realidade Claro que não entendi a
gente está vivendo uma transição desse
modelo então ela só no momento em que a
aristocracia nasce como conceito
importantíssimo A Hierarquia e o poder
era muito claro existiam pessoa que pela
intelectualidade chegaria ao algum lugar
e eu tô falando esse especificamente de
um padrão europeu de pessoa as pessoas
brancas e similares a esse modelo
eurocêntrico do que significa ser bom
Belo e inteligente e outra tenta nós
temos as pessoas que vão chegar no lugar
de riqueza e poder a partir dos seus
esforços pessoais brancas essas pessoas
também tem cor essas pessoas são as
pessoas negras e essas pessoas também
tem origem essas pessoas com as pessoas
indígenas Olha só em países colonizados
como o nosso a gente tem a expressão do
a qualidade muito focada num padrão
específico de pessoas e do que é força e
utilitarismo da cidade do exercício
físico as pessoas negras Olha como aí
ele aqui zação dos sujeitos que deu esse
da ainda de forma muito similar ao que
aconteceu em 1500 quando nós fomos
colonizados pelos europeus Mas você
começou a falar de meritocracia E agora
você tá falando de contexto social
exatamente naquele contexto histórico
nós temos uma Europa usando sendo usada
como centro do mundo isso não mudou
muito Qual é o sentido de nós
atribuirmos um valor a meritocracia num
país onde as pessoas não partem no mesmo
lugar
E nenhuma é verdade foi bem Eu estou
falando de um paradigma dominante que
está dando lugar a um paradigma
emergente onde a meritocracia ela
encontra uma grande divergência de toda
a sociedade porque o abismo social ele
está escancarado nós estamos
transacionando de um modelo de sociedade
para um modelo mais interconectado de
maior interconexão entre as pessoas e
por que isso porque nós vivemos um
momento hiperconectado tecnologicamente
estamos vivendo a era da informação esse
novo modelo de sociedade está
fundamentalmente ligado por um novo
tecido social que é a tecnologia muito
bom e aí a gente também continua podendo
não podendo falar de metal Cassiana eu
digo que pode se apresentar uma outra
confusão se naquele momento a gente
tinha vai tocar fica ligada as pessoas
indígenas e de pele negra como algo
muito difícil porque a gente nunca ia
ter não vai ter condições
a física suficiente para entregar nossa
força de trabalho a ponto da gente
chegar em algum cargo de liderança ou
tem algum poder onde mobilidade social
porque é impossível o caminho para esse
lugar não se faz por meio da força e do
outro lado nós temos pessoas e
intelectuais no lugar especial reservado
a essas pessoas mais conectadas ao
padrão europeu do que é inteligência
beleza ou aceitação certo e nesse
momento gente que tem que a meritocracia
não faz sentido porque eu estou falando
que quando eu coloco a tecnologia para o
jogo eu estou excluindo uma parcela
muito maior da população de chegar nesse
lugar por meio da meritocracia se aquele
momento histórico eu tinha a
intelectualidade como único caminho e o
serviço braçal que era atribuído
necessariamente as pessoas que estavam
numa classe social mais inferiorizada
por que a classe mais abastada curva
precisava dos trabalhos dessas pessoas
tá podendo e se manter Onde estão eu tô
dizendo que hoje o nosso Abismo social
pode
é porque a tecnologia ela não está
visível para todo mundo muito menos no
país como o Brasil Aqui nós temos
lugares onde se quer saneamento básico
existe que tem sabe uma antena de TV é
quase improvável que está à tecnologia
eu estou falando que essas pessoas
também tem cor e classe social Nós
deixamos a margem com uma parcela
gigantesca da população embora sejamos
um país essencialmente negro cuja 56 por
cento da população se declara como tal
nós não nos reconhecemos como pessoas em
cargos de liderança e poder de decisão
suficiente para poder direcionar os
rumos que a sociedade vai tomar então
novamente nós estamos passando por uma
transição de modelo social e se nós não
nos alertarmos nós estaremos
contribuindo para esse Abismo A partir
dessa nova sociedade da informação e da
tecnologia gente se eu tô dizendo que
até mesmo modelo do capitalismo como se
apresenta e se apresentou até hoje e
contribuiu tanto para que a gente
pudesse difundiu com
a fotografia ele tá sendo transacionado
por um novo modelo de capitalismo que a
gente pode chamar de Capitalismo de
vigilância de acordo com o que a
tecnologia nos trai porque simples os
dados eles são negócios o seu nome o seu
CPF quando colocado dentro de uma
plataforma digital que não cobrado nada
de você pode ter certeza que você é um
produto E eu acho que não é a primeira
vez que você escuta essa frase talvez
você já tenha escutado em outras
oportunidades Então o meu convite para
vocês hoje é se tentar na pele tocar a
cia nunca foi algo necessário porque
você fazia parte da população que
trabalha intelectualmente e com os
lugares reservados a você então sim de
atenção e mobilidade social voltadas ao
seu intelecto aos privilégios de uma cor
de pele você precisa pensar agora quer
ficar na litografia ela não só pode ser
ampliado ela pode não só ampliar a
desigualdade social como ela apresentar
uma nova problemática que é a
o habilidade de nós colocaremos novos
agentes e dessa vez para além da cor da
pele também lendário sinalização social
também fora da possibilidade de se
desenvolverem economicamente e fazerem
parte das pessoas que podem viver com
tranquilidade pensando no futuro porque
elas não têm acesso e acesso é o que nos
falta e nos faltará a cada vez mais se
não entendemos que quando a tecnologia
toma posição numa sociedade os valores
humanos precisam ser os mais fortes
porque o nosso tecido social precisa
estar conectado com que nós temos de
único e que nunca poderá ser substituído
que a nossa humanidade a nossa
capacidade de olhar uns para os outros e
entender que se não foram todos juntos
Muito provavelmente o futuro não vai ser
feito para nenhum de nós